it's really lit and fun and crazy it's
not crazy I don't even remember lights I
got a TV show to be honest neither too
weak the kardashian-jenner 's have
dominated pop culture over the past
decade so buckle your seat belts as et
takes a look at the famous family's most
memorable moments throughout the 2010
[Music]
in August 2011 Kim married NBA player
Kris Humphries just 72 days later she
filed for divorce which made fans wonder
if the marriage was a publicity stunt
but Kim denied that during a sit-down
interview with Oprah Winfrey we don't do
anything for ratings and then I just
think anyone that knows me knows that I
love so hard I fall in love fast the
tough decision to end that relationship
with such a risk of losing ratings and
losing my fan base Kim's happily ever
after came in 2014 when she tied the
knot with Kanye West the couple went on
to have four kids together
North saint-jacques hago and salt we're
definitely a close family like more than
probably normal in 2016 Kimmy a put on a
united front as their feud with Taylor
Swift played out in the public eye there
was a lot of drama like major major
drama it all started when Taylor claims
she didn't give Kanye permission to use
this lyric in his song famous I made
that famous Kim came through with
receipts leaking snippets of a recorded
phone call between Taylor and Kanye
discussing her name droppin the song but
by 2019 Kim told Andy Cohen on watch
what happens live that their beef had
been squashed still a beef with Taylor
after all that went down knows over it
but the most traumatizing moment of
Kim's life happened in October 2016 when
she was held at gunpoint inside her
hotel room in Paris I have a split
second in my mind to make this quick
decision like am I gonna run down the
stairs and like either be shot in the
back legs it makes me so upset to think
about it but like either they're gonna
shoot me in the back or if I make it and
they don't if the elevator does not open
in time or the stairs are locked then
like I'm you are
husband and wife
[Music]
Chloe married NBA star Lamar Odom in
2009 one month after they first met
she's the boss yes but sadly in 2013
khlomoney filed for divorce how do you
feel
sucks just sucks definitely feel guilty
fast forward to October 2015 Lamar was
found unconscious in a Nevada brothel to
get to a hospital in here that someone
has four hours to live and there's
nothing you can really do it's horrible
Khloe withdrew the divorce papers and
stayed by Lamar's side throughout his
recovery
Lamar wasn't able to walk he had no
facial recognition he did not know
people's names when something as tragic
as this happens it does make you hold on
to life and think about things you're
more in the moment
shortly after KOCO refiled and the pair
finalized their divorce in December 2016
but they've remained supportive of one
another I'm really proud of him for that
fight and his will to want to get better
if you could say one thing to Khloe
right now what would you say thank you
for being there for me when I can't walk
or talk my piece of paper just says that
we're not together it looked like Khloe
finally found her happy ending with NBA
player Tristan Thompson in December 2017
the couple announced they were expecting
a baby together it's such a beautiful
thing but just days before their
daughter trues birth the couple was
plagued by scandal
Tristan made headlines after footage
leaked of what appeared to be him making
out with an unknown woman at a New York
City nightclub making matters worse a
second video was published this one
allegedly showed Tristan kissing and
getting cozy with two women at a hookah
lounge a source told et at the time that
Khloe was quote completely devastated
like I don't even know how to describe
it besides it's just so the couple
worked on rebuilding their relationship
but were rocked by an even bigger
scandal in February 2000 19 when Tristan
was accused of cheating on Khloe again
with Kylie Jenner's BFF Jordan Woods on
the way out
he did kiss me like a tongue kiss like a
peck on the lips
Peck love like a no it was like a kiss
on the lips
but no tongue kiss no making out nothing
and of course the drama was documented
on Keeping Up with the Kardashians this
is my over the last decade the youngest
kardashian-jenner sister Kylie has grown
up before our eyes in 2015
Kylie went public with her first
high-profile romance with rapper Tyga I
love having T around I feel like he just
keeps me sane their love connection
eventually fizzled and Kylie moved on
with another rapper Travis Scott in
February 2018
Kylie manifested her biggest dream I
can't wait
even on 15 I would love the couple
revealed they had a baby together a
daughter named stormy impressively they
managed to keep Kylie's entire pregnancy
a secret releasing a video documenting
the entire journey after stormy was
already born
[Music]
not only did Kylie become a mom in this
decade she also became a billionaire
thanks to her wildly successful makeup
line Kylie cosmetics had the opportunity
to make like the coolest makeup Lana
always dreamed up it's really my only
passion kendall spent the last decade
playing the field being romantically
linked to NBA stars like Blake Griffin
and Ben Simmons and rapper ASAP Rocky I
like to keep my private life pretty
private over the past ten years kendall
also cemented her status as one of the
most sought-after supermodels in the
world walking runways and appearing in
campaigns for designers like Versace
Chanel and Victoria's Secret a full
dream come true I really did not expect
me anytime in the near future to ever be
wearing this robe and be in this room so
but Kendall's career hasn't been all
smooth sailing in 2017 she was
reportedly paid two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for an Instagram post
promoting fire festival which turned out
to be a disastrous and fraudulent music
festival just a few months later kendall
was embroiled in another controversy
[Music]
that's the now-infamous Pepsi commercial
that sparked huge outrage with some fans
accusing the brand of mocking the black
lives matter movement
Pepsi apologized for the ad and pulled
the commercial entirely while Kendall
addressed the backlash on Keeping Up
I would never purposely hurt someone
ever I just felt so stupid
the fact that I would offend other
people or hurt other people was
definitely not the intent Courtney has
three kids she's never looked better
she's like the hottest mom ever
the oldest Kardashian's sister Courtney
started her family with longtime beau
Scott Disick in December 2009 they
welcomed the first member of the new
generation of Kardashian's a son named
Mason and went on to have a daughter
named Penelope and another son named
rain but Kourtney and Scott split in
2015 after photos surfaced online of
Scott getting handsy with his ex Chloe
Bartoli
in the South of France that worked so
hard to like keep this family together
it just makes me sad for the kids
since then the former couple has
prioritized co-parenting they even
vacation together with Scott's new
girlfriend Sophia Richie we decided that
we wanted our kids to have these
memories together as a family and I know
every time you take the kids on a trip
and I don't go you invite me because you
would never want another like I don't
wouldn't want you to miss out on that
life is a challenge and if you work at
what you want if you get it but it takes
hard work simple as that you can easily
live less of a life without working as
hard that's Rob the only male Kardashian
sibling mostly stayed out of family
drama until 2016 the year he got engaged
to blac Chyna and welcomed a baby girl
named dream
[Music]
at the time Rob's sister Kylie was
dating Tyga and Tyga previously had a
baby with China
China is also close pals with Amber Rose
Kanye West's ex
who hasn't exactly gotten along with the
famous fam their entire relationship was
tumultuous and the drama came to a head
in 2017 Rob accused China of cheating on
him and posted a series of nude pics
that appeared to be of China China
responded with claims that Rob abused
her during their relationship which he
denies but later that year they reached
a custody agreement and by 2019 and they
even praised each other as parents on
social media are you a woman yes for all
intensive purposes I am a woman in a
2015 interview with Diane Sawyer Caitlyn
Jenner came out as a trans woman Bruce
always telling a lie slip though I his
whole life about who he is and I can't
do that any longer Jenner's new look was
debuted on the July 2015 cover of Vanity
Fair and officially revealed her new
name Caitlyn she also got her own
spin-off series I am Cait which
documented her experience transitioning
thinking about my family and I'm
thinking about others kind of stuff I'm
struggling with it what I'm hoping for
is that the world is gonna follow along
with me and we can learn together
Caitlyn spoke with et about her cultural
impact one year after she revealed her
new identity we started a conversation
about a small segment of our population
but they are out there that have been
persecuted the suicide rate is so high
and for the last year what about you but
it's been the most amazing year of
people coming up and talking about this
issue it's been great had really husband
through it all the glue of the family
momager Kris Jenner as a boss I'm tough
the proud mama of six successfully
launched all of her kids careers and
over the past ten years she's helped
them thrive and flourish I set the bar
really high and my motto in life is if
someone says no you're talking to the
wrong person
Chris's personal life has s o made
headlines in 2013 she and Caitlyn
announced their separation after 23
years of marriage in 2014 she started
dating Cory gamble who's 25 years her
junior the pair have been inseparable
ever since
Cory even pops up on keeping up from
time to time I feel like then what your
mom is better I'm doing with her me
shake my age but mama Chris insists
she's in no rush to get married when are
we going to have wedding bells for you
from breakups to makeups babies and
businesses we can't wait to keep up with
the Kardashian Jenner's in the next
decade we know they won't disappoint I'm
still having so much fun doing it yeah
so I'm not ready to stop
[Music]